[Applause]
thank you all thanks paul
thanks everyone for coming out
[Music]
this looks good can you hear me
lower oh for the camera no
already botched my first appearance on
c-span
i guess i'd like to first
thank c-span's book tv for featuring my
reading
on your program and i'd like to thank
mission creek festival for making me a
part of the literary lineup which is
amazing and thank prairie lights not
only for hosting this reading but for
giving writers like me and many other
people a place to write in public much
of this book was written at the coffee
shop
american wit and wisdom began with some
mass mediated mischief
in the december 19th
in the december 19 1732 edition of the
pennsylvania gazette benjamin franklin
pinned the following advertisement quote
just published for 1733 poor richard an
almanac containing the lunations
eclipses planet motions and aspects
weather and the prediction of the death
of his friend mr titan leeds
end quote writing under the name richard
saunders he not only narrowed down the
date of leads
of leeds death to the date and time
october 17 1733 at 3 29 p.m but also the
exact moment when two worldly bodies
aligned
quote at the very instance of the
conjunction of sun and mercury
franklin was a rationalist project a
product of the enlightenment
who heaped scorn
on astrologers like titan leads more
crucially leeds was a business rival and
the printer's way up the ladder of
wealth was often achieved by stepping on
his competitors
franklin claimed that the two friends
frequently debated when the cosmos had
scheduled leeds's appointment with a
grim reaper quote but at length he is
inclinable to agree with my judgment
which is
most exact
and a little time will tell
end quote
when titan leads did not die on that
date phase two of operation ridicule
astralis astrologer
kicked into gear
in the next poor richard's almanac
franklin saunders bemoaned the fact that
he couldn't attend to his best friend
during the final moments on earth
oh how he wished to have given leeds a
farewell embrace close his eyes and say
goodbye one last time
this infuriated the astrologer who
ranted in his not quite posthumous 1734
almanac about this false predictor
conceded scribbler fool and last but not
least liar
poor richard was shocked by these rude
utterances with a weary tone he wrote
having received much abuse from the
ghost of titan leads who pretends to
still be living and write almanex in
spite of me and my predictions i cannot
help but saying that though i take it
patiently i take it very unkindly
end quote he added that there was
absolutely no doubt that leeds had died
for it was quote plain to everyone who
reads the last two almanacs that no man
living could or would write such damn
stuff
benjamin franklin owned and operated the
printing press that turned out his
competitor's almanac giving him a
crucial advantage in this war of words
this inside knowledge allowed franklin
to read read his attacks leads his
attacks
uh before they even went to press and
respond to them
quote mr leeds was too well bred to use
any man so indecently and seriously
franklin wrote further egging him on and
moreover his esteem and affection for me
was extraordinary
the astrologers protest continued to
pour fuel on the fire which by then had
captivated much of the colony's reading
public
franklin kept this up for several years
and even after the astrologer really did
die in 1738
then uh so for instance the 1740 edition
of poor richard's almanac described a
late night visit from the ghost of titan
leeds who entered richard saunders brain
via his left nostril and and pin the
following message i actually did die at
that moment he finally confessed
precisely at the hour you admission with
just a variation of 5 minutes and 53
seconds
benjamin franklin's ruse is the first
modern or one of the first modern
examples of what i call a prank
in the groundbreaking book pranks andrea
juno and vivale suggest that quote the
best pranks invoke imagination poetic
imagery the unexpected and a deep level
of irony and social criticism
by staging these semi-serious
semi-humorous spectacles pranksters can
spark important debates and in some
instances provoke social change
unfortunately the word prank is more
often used today to describe stunts that
make people look foolish and little more
i'm not interested in celebrating
cruelty especially the sorts of
mean-spirited practical jokes hazing
rituals and reality television deceits
that are far too common in today's pop
culture
although good pranks sometimes do
ridicule their targets they serve a
higher purpose by sowing skepticism and
speaking truth to power or at least
cracking jokes that expose fissures and
powers facade
a prank a day keeps the man away i
always say
nevertheless i should stress at the
outset that this book is not solely
about pranking many of the characters
who populate the these pages aren't
driven by noble impulses and even those
who are are more pure of heart can muddy
the ethical waters with dubious tactics
so with this in mind pranksters examines
everything from political pranks silly
hoaxes and con games to the sorts of
self-deception that fuel outland
outlandish belief systems
though these may seem like very
different examples
they are linked by the fact that all
varieties of deceit engender confusion
uncertainty and ambiguity
spectators whether they've been scammed
by a swindler or witnessed a satirical
street theater performance
can experience a single event in
radically different ways
one person's prank can become fodder for
another person's con
or as we'll soon see conspiracy theory
pranks hoaxes cons and conspiracy
theories
share another key similarity
people buy into them when they resonate
with their own deeply entrenched world
views
conversely they can also push us to
think more critically about how and why
we come to embrace false beliefs
while at the same time reminding us not
to
repeat past mistakes as the old proverb
goes fool me once shame on you fool me
twice shame on me though i preferred g.w
bush's version of that
by viewing modern history through the
lens of trickery this book offers an
offbeat and overlooked account of
political religious and social life in
the west
yes reason and enlightenment principles
shaped modernity but so did chicanery
and irrationality
pranks also provide a real life learning
lab for conducting social experiments
anyone with enough pluck luck and
imagination can open the hood of the
culture industry's engine and watch the
gears turn
one useful example is the banana hoax in
1967 a rumor circulated that one could
get high by smoking banana peels though
in reality the only way to trip on a
banana is to step on one
sorry
the instigators were most likely country
joe mcdonald and gary chicken hirsch
from the acid damage jug band country
joe and the fish
in late 1966 they started spreading the
word among friends that banana peels
contain psychedelic ingredients
even if it didn't work hirsch said of
their druggy effects it was great fun
end quote
not only would this fruit be absurdly
difficult to outlaw but the thought of
puffing on bananas contain more than a
whiff of slapstick silliness
the story initially traveled via word of
mouth and the first printed account
appeared on in a
march 1967 issue of the berkeley barb
conveniently ed dennison served as
country joe's band manager and also
contributed to a regular uh contributed
irregular music column to that
underground newspaper
quote i was fully involved in
perpetrating the hoax when i wrote that
article denson later admitted though he
denied pinning a letter to the editor
about a cop and local food co and the
local food co-op who is quote lurking in
the fresh produce section
the writer predicted that possessing
large amounts of bananas would soon
become a criminal offense
the smokable banana myth is a bit
frivolous sure but we can still learn a
lot from how it took root historian john
mcmillan notes that this prank reveals
much about the social and media
landscapes of the time
underground newspapers created a virtual
community connecting weirdos radicals
and dropouts living in cities suburbs
and rural areas
this alternative communication network
ensured that few things remained local
mainstream outlets also propagated this
put on starting with the san francisco
chronicle in an article titled kicks for
hippies the banana turn on
within a month time and newsweek piled
on with a wink and soon it was part of
popular folklore
quote from bananas it's a short but
shocking step to other fruits said
congressman frank thompson who cheekily
proposed to the
banana labeling act of 1967.
in a speech on the floor of the house of
representatives he declared quote today
the cries burn banana burn tomorrow we
may face strawberry smoking dried
apricot inhaling or prune puffing
thompson claimed that a quote high
official at the fda end quote urged him
to introduce the bill
but the food and drug administration
didn't actually find the banana smoking
rumor very funny in fact they uh they
designed various studies to detect
uh well they released a press release
that soberly stated ultimately that it
failed to find quote
detectable quantities of known
hallucinogens and bananas end quote i
finished that sentence thank god
pop music also helps spread this
mischievous meme uh donovan's recent hit
mellow yellow was widely re
rumored to be about you know what
electrical banana is going to be the
latest craze he's saying
but the song was actually written before
the prank was hatched it was just some
kooky cosmic coincidence
the constant repetition of mellow yellow
on radios amplified the banana hoax as
it spread through subterranean
tributaries corporate channels and word
of mouth
a famous rumor about the beatles paul
mccartney known as the paula's dead hoax
followed a similar pattern in 1969 news
spread that he died in a car accident
and had been replaced by look and sound
alike the story originally appeared in
an iowa college newspaper drake's paper
and fanned out through underground
newspapers free-form fm radio and other
counter-cultural media outlets
time and life also ran with it and soon
legions of stone hippies were pouring
over the fab four's albums in search of
clues about mccartney's demise it was
all in good fun but not everyone
appreciated this sort of tomfoolery in
the case of the banana hoax some
radicals even called it
counter-revolutionary
students for a democratic society
president todd gitlin gitlin insisted
that it was a politically misguided
stunt that ignored the united fruit
company's unfair labor practices
these circumstances come to mind he
grumbled when bananas are flaunted with
humor or symbolic meaning as a means of
liberation end quote although gitland
did have a legitimate point he was
fighting an uphill battle
the ruptures produced by the gay and
women's liberation struggles combined
with the black power and anti-war
movements created multiple openings for
irreverent tricksters
the trickster tradition
russian literary critic mikhail bakhtin
believed that lacks uh laughter has
played an underrecognized role in
steering history when hilarity erupts it
can also interrupt the status quo he
claimed that the old feudal order wasn't
just brought down with cannonballs and
enlightenment thought but but also by
waves of uninhibited laughter
medieval carnivals gave peasants the
license to turn existing power relations
upside down if only for a day by
ridiculing kings and princes
even christmas oh these raucous rituals
occurred in all countries throughout
europe creating an
alternative space that thrived outside
of the political
and religious
spheres the official political and
religious spheres even christmas had an
early unruly incarnation although some
christians did piously observe this
holiday and shunned the wild
celebrations associated with it
that those folks were few and far
between late december festivities took
place for centuries and they coincided
with a
moment of leisure and abundance that
came with the end of the harvest
during this time of year the social
hierarchy was symbolically turned upside
down the lowly became the masters of
misrule men dressed as women and vice
versa children gained the status of
their elders who were ruthlessly mocked
in 17th century new england the holiday
troubled religious leaders so much that
they banned christmas entirely attention
fox news the puritans waged the first
war on christmas
historian stephen nisselbaum notes quote
when the church more than a millennium
earlier had placed christmas day in late
december the decision was part
of what amounted to a compromise a
compromise for which the church paid a
very high price end quote
folding a rowdy secular festival into
this holy christian holiday created
serious headaches for
religious authorities
despite the liberatory promise of
medieval carnivals they sometimes
unleashed frustrations violent
frustrations against jews and other
minority groups
these officially sanctioned subversions
also functioned as instruments of social
control by letting people blow off steam
before tensions exploded
nevertheless they did plant seeds that
occasionally overturn the ruling order
as lewis hyde puts it quote
every so often fat tuesday does leak
over into lean wednesday and into the
rest of the year as well
in germany the ceremonial debasement of
the pope helped lay the groundwork for
the reformation
as lewis hyde says again the ritual
container broke the pollution leaked out
and the church itself was fundamentally
altered
it was the gefa heard around the world a
reminder of media theoristic hebdidge's
claim that quote the modern age was
laughed into being
invoking bakhtin he writes the dust and
the cobwebs the angels and the devils
the necromancers and the priests the
barbaric inquisitions the inflexible
hierarchies the sober deadly serious
ignorance of the medieval powers were
blown away not by guns and great debates
but by great gusts of belly laughter
so chapter 1 starts
exactly 400 years ago in 1614.
the modern era was ushered in by a prank
in 1614 a mysterious tract appeared in
castle germany announcing the existence
of an invisible college of mystical
adepts
can't say speak latin so i'll just call
it fama for now on uh or in english the
fame of the brotherhood of the rose
cross told the tale of a man named
christian rosencruz
rosen cruz founded the brotherhood
supposedly in 1408 and it met yearly in
the mysterious house of the holy spirit
the trope of a young christian who
traveled east and gained new wisdom was
not uncommon within the popular culture
of that time though the story of a
hero's journey and homecoming has much
older roots and myth so within that
context fama clearly reads like an
allegory though that didn't stop many
people from taking it literally
the first tract combined with an
anonymous 1615 pamphlet titled confessio
fraternitatus
damulatin um as well as 1616's the
chemical wedding of christian
rosencrutes formed the core of what
became known as the rosicrucian
manifestos these documents these
documents claimed that the brothers of
the rose cross were engineering a coming
golden age that would transform all
existing political and religious
institutions
not only could these men bring apart uh
bring about global utopian harmony they
could make themselves disappear
readers who wanted to meet a brother
were instructed that if they
concentrated really really hard one
would probably drop by for a visit
the family manuscript initially
circulated in rarefied circles
stimulating thoughtful debate and
contemplation
the published version which took the
prank public however was reframed as a
full-blown political religious diatribe
that downplayed the original subtlety it
blew up like a mass-mediated bomb
mass-mediated bomb
this had the comical effect of sending
people scrambling in search of an
invisible fraternity even though fama
clearly made the hippy-dippy claim that
one could only realize the true nature
of the brotherhood by looking deep
within oneself
the authors of the rosicrucian
manifestos were primarily drawn to
esoteric learning science and technology
they also shared an irreverent or
outright hostile attitude towards
catholicism
this had the catalytic effect of
splitting public opinion down religious
lines
catholics blasted these heretics while
others sought to join or claim their
arty members or knew someone who was
reports from the period spoke of a
hurricane of excitement both pro and
khan whipped up by this imaginary secret
society the catholic church insisted
that the rosicrucians were devil
worshipers
whose promise of enlightenment was clear
evidence of a diabolical agenda
furthermore the brotherhood's
self-proclaimed shape-shifting abilities
let them supposedly infiltrate political
and religious institutions
and finally their interest in natural
philosophy which was a precursor to
modern science was assumed to be wicked
bait used to twist the minds of
christians
the lines between occultism esoteric
knowledge and natural philosophy were
quite blurry in this era even sir isaac
newton spent more time on alchemy than
gravitational science
rene de carr was rumored to be a
rosicrucian something he famously had to
deny but nevertheless the mathematician
was excited enough to write in his notes
about quote the distinguished brothers
of the rose cross in germany
descartes sought after them in 1916-19
but it was a fruitless quest as the
manifestos instructed one could only
find a brother by entering a world of
imagination or a new consciousness as
the beatles saying turn off your mind
relax and float downstream
despite the uh manifesto shadowy origins
some consistent uh some consensus
consensus has formed about who authored
them
a radical german theologian named johann
andre later confessed to writing the
chemical wedding and he was also the
probable author of the first manifesto
that kicked things off fama
the relatively new technology of the
printing press was key to the prank's
success especially because fama invited
quote all of the scholars and rulers of
europe to declare their minds in print
end quote in a stroke of marketing
genius no return address was given
european intellectuals tried their best
to attract the brotherhood's attention
and within a dozen years imitators and
detractors produced several hundred
pamphlets books and broadsides an
astounding amount for that period
andre characterized what he did as a
youthful
la
ladubrium
another latin word i should have taken
latin in high school or a joke with a
serious objective in his autobiography
he expressed shock
he expressed shock that people took his
parody seriously claiming that the
chemical wedding was intended to trap
the credulous andre explicitly used
theatrical and gaming metaphors to talk
about his prank describing how he wrote
the script set the scene and watched the
drama unfold
by wrapping famous cry for spiritual
revolt in a dramatic tale about quest
and discovery it pulled a curious public
even further into this
web of intrigue andre hoped that this
theatrical game would encourage people
to be more accepting of new ideas about
science philosophy and spirituality but
by in 1619 he grew exasperated listen ye
mortals andre advised in vain do you
wait for the coming of the brotherhood
this comedy is at an end end quote
he called it the parent of all follies
and uh the heart and scandal of
occultism in his time
the the pranksters in this case
lost control of the narrative uh and the
resulting fuhrer
uh ended up basically obscuring the
intended message
it was the first in a long line of
pranks that took on a life of their own
going viral in ways that the original
authors or actors or directors never
intended
this dialed up uh
yeah
this all of this uh sorry
the resulting prank blowback
exploded into a social force that
impacted four centuries of western
culture
regardless of whether this invisible
college was a genuine secret society or
a provocative prank the rosie christian
manifestos left a deep footprint in the
material world
after trying to get the attention of the
brotherhood in print to no avail many
interested parties started their own
rosicrucian orders the meme continued to
self-replicate and it went on to
influence the religious pluralism of
freemasonry and others who challenged
tradition
the myth of the rosicrucian brotherhood
also created the template for virtually
every occultic conspiracy theory that
followed an elite body of initiates a
satanic secret society within a secret
society sometimes known as the
illuminati that wants to overthrow all
established religious political
authority and create a new world order
so that was from my introduction
and so i'm going to read from chapter 7
political pranksters
the 1968 demonstration against the miss
america pageant was a turning point for
the women's liberation movement they
designed their zap prot their zap action
to provoke a debate about beauty
pageants and the patriarchal society
that props them up
quote there are about 35 of us says roz
payne a member of the newsreel film
collective and also a founding member of
which the women's
the women's international terrorist
conspiracy from hell
so she tells me we got on the bus and
traveled down from new york to atlantic
city and had a little fun
to dramatize women's enslavement to
beauty standards for instance some of
them chained themselves to a gigantic
miss america puppet
they took a cue from the yipi's pig for
president campaign by using a sheep to
quote parody the way the contestants are
appraised and judged like animals at a
county fair
um
so roz payne tells me we crown the sheep
uh miss america some men
someone gave us the thumbs down i
remember one guy saying i like the
ladies
a few got arrested when an inside squad
of 20 women disrupted the pageants live
broadcast they screamed freedom for
women and unfurled a banner that
trumpeted women's liberation which
stopped the pageant for 10 excruciating
seconds
the television audience could tell
something was wrong miss america
trembled and stuttered after the
shouting began but it was unclear
exactly what was going on
another woman was arrested for spraying
the mayor's seating area with tony hair
conditioner a pageant sponsor
the police arrest report referred to it
as a noxious odor which wasn't exactly
the best product placement for the
company
the women refused to speak with male
reporters although this was spun by
critics as knee-jerk man-hating it was a
calculated gesture meant to highlight
women's marginalized place in the
newsroom and their general distrust of
media
and they had good reasons to distrust
mainstream media especially because the
protests most memorable
event bra burning never took place
i never saw a bra burn in my entire life
says roz payne who filmed the miss
america protests she adds laughing is
probably a man who started that story
as it turns out the bra burning urban
legend can be traced back to a young
female reporter for the new york post
which was not yet owned by rupert
murdoch
lindsey van gelder wrote an article that
drew parallels between the miss america
protest and another contemporary form of
mass resistance draft card burning her
satirical article bra burners in miss
america backfired when its ironic tone
was lost in translation
the mental image of bra burning quickly
took root in public memory
even though there is absolutely no
photographic evidence that to verify
that it happened
people just filled in the blanks with
their imagination
robin morgan noted at the time that the
bras toast that they tossed into the
freedom trash can was quote translated
by the male controlled media into the
totally fabricated act of broad burning
a non-event which they have fixated on
constantly ever since end quote
what she didn't say was that the event
organizers herself included actually did
plan to set fire to the trash can but
atlantic city officials denied their
permit on the grounds that it was a fire
hazard the boardwalk was made of wood
in feminist historian alice eckel's
history of the movement she notes that
at least one of the organizers hoping to
stir up interests uh leaked word of the
plan broad burning to the press
beforehand quote those feminists who
sanctimoniously disavowed the broad
burning as a media fabrication echols
insists were either misinformed or
disingenuous end quote
once the bra burning meme was unleashed
the women's movement lost control of the
narrative and was used as a bludgeon to
caricature feminism
so i'm going to give you one last
sample from the book and then i'll open
it up to q a
popular culture is an inviting space for
trickster figures entertainers generally
have more leeway than your average
person to push the boundaries of
convention because they tend to be well
entertaining bitter truths can be
swallowed more easily with a dollop of
sugar and spice
the eccentric otherness exuded by early
television star quarla pandit
was made more palatable by a spectacle
that featured hypnotic music and
striking costumes and sets
one can get away with with almost
anything by making people tap their toes
or laugh or shake their heads in
disbelief this is also true of gorgeous
george's gender bending wrestling act
and muhammad ali's in and out of ring
dustups
come
come with us through melody to the four
corners of the earth the ktla station
announcer said as an as an attractive
and enigmatic man gaze directly into the
camera
here music exotic and familiar spring
from the amazing hands of corlapandit on
a musical adventure
an androgynous figure massaged the organ
with his slender fingers looking a bit
like purple rain era prince and a
jeweled turban
coral a pandit's adventures in music was
the first all music show on television
and it was an instant hit in 1948 airing
five days a week for over 900 episodes a
tv guide named it the best show in los
angeles pandit won the magazine's top
male personality honors and he released
more than two dozen records over the
course of two decades
even though pandit was silent on camera
friends joked that he would never shut
up in person
the organist loved to talk about his
privileged childhood in new delhi where
his father was a government bureaucrat
and a friend of gandhi
he also claimed that his mother was a
french opera singer though the truth was
more mundane pandit was a black man from
the midwest
he was light-skinned about the color of
uh general colin powell says stan
freeberg who worked with him at ktla to
tell you the truth i think corella
pandit invented himself
the saint louis native was born in 1921
as john roland red and began his radio
career at a cbs affiliate in iowa
in the late 1930s he followed several of
his sisters to california where he
worked as a staff musician on network
radio shows red adopted the name juan
rolando and performed everything from
country and western to big band jazz
then in 1948 he dropped his mexican
identity and changed his name to coral a
pandit that year he recorded stampede
with rory rogers and the sons of the
pioneers who dubbed him cactus pandit
it was surely the first and quite
possibly the last time a black man
passing as a turban-clad indian ever
played on a country record
corliss beautiful blonde wife beryl
panda a former disney studios airbrush
artist was instrumental in crafting his
persona a tv swani swamy with hypnotic
musical powers
she designed the sets worked with
lighting technicians and costumed her
husband
a program with no talking and only organ
music surely would not fly today but the
rules of this new medium were still up
for grabs
people just didn't really know what tv
was supposed to be
ktla was also an independent broadcaster
which gave it more flexibility than its
network competitors
shows were live they were rough around
the edges and they offered a dizzying
variety of musical entertainment harry
owens and his royal hawaiians
aina rae hutton and her all-girl
orchestra liberace and of course corella
pandit
there are also cooking programs a
variety show on ice puppet theater and a
weird comedy named year old buddy in
which a flustered man tried to explain
the mechanic machinations of a
television studio to viewers
oddest of all was ktla's decision to
broadcast an atomic test explosion live
quote all this was done without any
advanced publicity said johnny paulich
who worked at the station 30 seconds
before the blast we cut the food show
off the air and just went on
which must have made for some jarring
viewing right
early television created a semi-anarchic
opening for pop culture trickster
figures to slip through the door and
shape this new medium in their image
with enough luck and pluck border
crossing outsiders could become insiders
this gave a jim crow era black man
access to the nation's airwaves enabling
coral a pandit to broadcast from an
alternate universe located inside his
imagination thank you
[Applause]
so yeah i can take questions and i guess
i'll direct the questions they're a
floating mic yeah
floating mic oh yeah okay also uh
um i have free trading cards you don't
have to buy my book but uh yeah that
here's one for my thank you so much i
really enjoyed your reading d-roy um
and i just want to make sure you got one
um but everyone else can come up here
and get one like i said it's not
required that you buy my book um and
they're also available down at the desk
for
probably a couple more weeks until they
run out and
tonight tonight these are free for
anyone who shows up to the reading but
usually the deal i strike with jan is uh
well if you buy any book again not just
my book any book um
from prairie lights you get a free set
of 20 pranksters trading cards with
benjamin franklin women's terrorist
women's international terrorist
conspiracy from hell and lots of other
andy kaufman card and so on okay so
questions
usually i end up yeah uh with that
dumbstruck silence after i speak right
uh kemper i've been a fan of the pranks
that you
uh
are the purveyor of for many years would
you mind telling everyone about
the mascot at jmu that you pulled a few
years back okay so
yeah i
one thing i didn't mention is there is a
little bit of like autobiography
memoir in there but only just briefly
and only when it's relevant and the book
is chronological and so i don't appear
until the very end um
not the very end but near the end
um and so the mascot changing prank was
the first thing that sort of changed the
way i think about media um
it was a class project and
i've long hated
sports as many of you know um or may
know and um i decided to start a
fictitious movement to change the
football team's mascot or james madison
university's mascot to a three-eyed pig
with antlers from a
bulldog a gray steel
like a steely gray bulldog
and
as i said it was a class project so but
i would have done it even not for credit
but i got an a in the course that was
cool
and
basically we thought it would be just
kind of fun to mess with people's heads
but we didn't realize how far out of
control um it would snowball and so
it started with me
passing around a petition to change the
mascot and somehow i got like 400
signatures which seemed to really
threaten this
duke dog
fan so they
uh passed around a counter petition
and then i got my friend who is the
student government association to uh
submit a bill to change the mascot and
even though there was no chance of a
passing it completely freaked out the
campus and so for instance a homecoming
that year the marching band wore
dog bones around their necks and a sign
of solidarity and spelled out we love
the duke dog
in their tubas
a friend reported to me that someone
threw
created an effigy of a three-eyed pig
with antlers stuffed animal thing and
threw it into the stands and it was just
devoured and stomped and when
when uh
yeah
when asked what was going on uh someone
said oh
some [ __ ] [ __ ] are trying to
change the mascot to a three i pick with
antlers so that was the sort of you know
this early early 90s rural virginia
college
um
so
then i didn't know anything about
writing press releases and i recently
found like in my archives like this
really ridiculously poorly written press
release but somehow news stations showed
up
and nbc and abc local affiliates and
then it rippled out to
most
of those affiliates throughout virginia
and then eventually made its way onto
cnn story about
we're still living the story
about controversial sports teams uh like
the redskins and the braves
and they used the three-eyed pig with
ant like they sandwiched the three-eyed
pig with antlers um story somehow into
that so it was
my grandmother called me and um from
wichita and thought i was on drugs
um i asked asked if i was on drugs
and
anyway
it just got me thinking about
you know if i a kind of clueless 20 year
old college student who had no idea how
to write a press release and i had a
budget for about
eight stamps
if if i could
do this imagine what you know
big companies are doing all the time
along with you know the lobbying firms
and the publicity firms that they hire
to you know shape what we read so it
fundamentally changed the way i think
about media and um it also sort of
kicked off
a sort of
quasi-career and pranks
thanks
well also tell us about the robot prank
robo professor oh so now i'm gonna i
should just read from the book but i
won't um
well okay so
in 2008
during the primaries bill clinton was
stumping for hillary at the imu
and
i'd been mad at him for years for many
reasons but one reason was what he did
to sister soldier who's a largely
forgotten figure but
her the name is actually entered the
lexicon of politics there's what's
called the sister soldier moment when
basically a politician
publicly tries to distance him or
herself from their their you know more
radical base um and so he called out
sister soldier for something that she
said to a reporter she was asked
she was asked to um
uh
this was right after the the
la riots in 1992 in which a white truck
driver was dragged out of his truck and
brutally beaten and she was asked by the
reporter uh
what was going on in the minds of the
people who did that and so
she it was a very thoughtful response
and
it included uh
the sentence black people are killing
black people on the streets every day
and the government doesn't care so why
not have a day in which you kill white
people but it was
why not have a day and kill white people
is what bill clinton called her out on
at jesse jackson's convention of the uh
gathering of the rainbow rainbow
convention um
uh his political organization and it was
uh just first of all it was
it was kind of like a prank but it was
like a mean-spirited prank because he
yeah he was
he was shading the truth in ways that uh
were well
bothered me for many years so anyway i
finally had the chance to confront him
about it but i'm not gonna
you can't get anywhere by just like
screaming and shrieking you know
bastard or whatever right like that it's
like if i'm in a crowd in the big imu
main room like i would have no effect if
i was just uh yeah shouting at him so i
decided to um dress like a robot um
dressed like a robot
and i talked my way into the the press
stand along with the bloggers and cnn
and stuff so the cameras were all around
me and i it was a reversible robot
costume so it was like i brought
everything in a gym bag a silver bicycle
helmet i had the silver shoes that
fortunately security didn't notice but
um
and i had this reversible black and
silver
jacket that sort of formed the the basis
of my costume
and uh i stood up and interrupted a
speech and said
bill clinton apologize to sister soldier
robots of the world want you to
apologize to sister soldier
and by the time i finished saying that
that you know
secret service and hillary staffers had
surrounded me and and pulled my high
school musical amplified microphone out
of my hands and
ushered me out but not before i'd thrown
up a bunch of little cards with a
website that had a uh
robot manifesto on it that explains
why because you know i knew that i would
be shut up really quickly anyway it uh
it ended up looping this was a monday
and ended up looping on the the cable
news network's echo chamber for
all week it became a huge story
and the uh
i got the name robo professor i
appropriated the name robo professor
from the des moines register which had
the headline robo professor confronts
clinton um
however i it was a it was in many ways a
failed prank because
it's it took me so long just now to sort
of set up the story to explain who
sister soldier was
um and what happened and and so on and
so
instead
uh for instance like a cnn anchor in
explaining what was going on and why i
did it uh that i still remember this
quote sister soldier was a black rapper
who called for a kill white people day
which bill clinton called racist
and it was that's like it would have
taken an intern with access to google
like seconds to figure out that
statement was completely wrong um and
unfortunately for those people who
didn't remember this that sister soldier
moment in the first place or only
vaguely did um
or yeah
basically for everyone like now the
thing that they remember was the news
stories that framed it that way so it
was a failed prank so when four years
later sarah palin came to the hamburg
inn i had a upgraded like 2.0 robot
costume it was superfly and um
i stood outside the hamburg um the
hamburg was packed with her supporters
waiting for her bus to arrive and the
reason i learned from my mistake the
bill clinton mistake which was it needs
to have a simpler message
so
i also one of the things i've learned
from pranking is um
you need a good hook also which is why
like for instance i thought of having a
robot protester in the first place with
bill clinton would help circulate the
story so with uh with uh
if i said sarah palin i didn't mean to
it was michelle bachman um did i say
sarah palin yeah yeah yeah it was
michelle bachman uh same basic thing um
and so
this time like my hook was robo
professor was coming out as gay as
because i knew the term gay robot would
be the perfect hook to like circulate
the story internationally and it did end
up becoming an international story and
so as soon as she got off the bus
first of all i also had the foresight to
get matt steele from little village to
um
shoot hd video of it like just cheap
consumer quality hd video camera just so
we could document it because i i also
knew that
you know blogs or possibly other news
outlets
would wanna would be more likely to
publish the story if it was embeddable
um and so basically matt filmed me as i
accosted
michelle bachmann as she got off the bus
and michelle bachmann not only are you a
robophobe or not only are you a
homophobe you're a robophobe uh you know
um
like uh i will not i will not leave
until you support equal rights for human
and gay robots
and so and so i follow her in um
and i only last about a minute uh i
start like yeah i uh people start like
chanting go back in the closet go back
in the closet
and i and i responded i cannot help
myself i was programmed to do this i am
gay and um
and then the manager of the hamburg
working the manager working at the time
uh said could you please leave and i
felt bad and for her especially and i
was like yeah of course
so i left um i was spoken to by the i
iowa city police officer who told me
there would be consequences if i
returned
and i said affirmative and
and um
and that was that and then i came back
to prairie lights coffee shop and
quickly edited the video that matt shot
matt steele shot down to like a minute
uploaded it to youtube and then within
three hours it would that full minute of
footage was used like on a msnbc program
about um so anyway yeah
and the the last thing i wanted to say
about it is and just trying to learn
from my mistakes my pranking mistakes
yeah
it was
even for people who disagreed with my
message
because i targeted something that was a
key part of michelle bachmann's
political identity her homophobia
you know even they understood in ways
that with the bill clinton prank it
didn't work
uh oh the mike's coming around
sorry
oh it's being taped sound
thank you um you talk a few times about
failed pranks or when people lose
control of the narrative that they
initially created
are there times where losing control of
that narrative uh actually doesn't
detract from the political message but
in fact enhances it or can you talk a
little bit about it maybe started out
failing but um somehow when when the
prankster lost control of it it
rebounded well that's a really
interesting question um and no i've
never actually found a case uh what i
have found is
when the narrative starts spinning out
of control
the
the key tactic is to is the big reveal
where so for for instance with the bill
clinton um
with bill clinton robo professor versus
bill clinton i um immediately crafted a
uh op-ed to the washington post which
published it explaining
what i did and explaining the context
explaining you know what uh bill clinton
did sister soldier who even the reporter
when asked the reporter who originally
interviewed her when asked said yes bill
clinton totally took her words out of
context um yeah so but um i haven't
found an instance where it's it spirals
wildly out of control and something good
or positive or productive or whatever
comes out of it but maybe i just wasn't
looking when i was doing research
but the big reveal that's really
important
you may have a section about this in the
book but maybe you could talk a bit
about um the yes men and how they kind
of fit into the whole prankster
tradition yeah the yes men um they've
been around for
uh about 15 years now um
and
one of their most famous pranks
was
when they sent out a press release
stating that dow chemical
was uh on the 20th anniversary of the
horrible chemical spill in bhopal india
which killed a lot of people and had
lots of long-term health effects for the
population
that the company union carbide that
purchased
that was responsible for this bill
um it was purchased by dao so the yes
men used the fact that
dao purchased union carbide as a fulcrum
to
well remind the world about what's still
going on in bhopal
and
so they sent out a press release they
set up a fake website
in which they said
um
dow chemical is going to sell off union
carbide and use the proceeds to
compensate the community and the victims
and so one bbc world news invited a dow
chemical official on which turned out to
be a yes man
and
dow chemical stocks crashed by like
three billion dollars uh within like uh
an hour or two uh they rebounded after
dow chemical was forced to say
no we're actually jerks and we're not
gonna compensate the victims
the victims of the company we now own
and uh that was huge because it wasn't
just
the fact that he got on the air and that
was viewed the first time by a few
million people probably um but that
story the reverb effects like
echoed um throughout media and it became
a really big story so it they they
succeeded i think because they reminded
the world of like what union carbide and
by extension dow chemical did i guess we
have time for one more question
actually uh the apology
the uh the the
yeah
sorry you mentioned something about the
big reveal and that uh the s-men prank
was actually
the apology they they
uh basically apologized for dao and that
was when the prank emerged and and
that's what made that such a powerful
statement yeah i was just trying to
simplify the story but yeah no i it's
yeah that i mean because that was
actually that was the thing that's yeah
it kicked things off um
got things rolling in terms of spreading
the word about that prank and reminding
the world but yeah one last question
anyone going once
okay
[Music]
if the if the big reveal is a defining
feature
of the prankster
um
is edward snowden
a prankster
is is julian assange prankster
um
i'm just curious to hear you know where
are the limits of the prankster and
other forms of say subversive descent
yeah
that's a great question i mean i don't
really have a typology of pranking um
aside from distinguishing between pranks
and hoaxes and cons
and they all use the same strategies the
only difference is the underlying
motives of the perpetrators
i would think that
what edward snowden did in terms of you
know
thinking about how he can use media to
well raise awareness about something
that deeply concerned him i think that
you know i would hesitate to call him a
prankster but i think
it still lines up with yeah the same
tactics that pranksters
use so
maybe he's a prankster though i'll think
about it these are all great questions
thanks so much everyone
all right guys both uh kamberu and d foy
would be happy to sign some books is
this yeah
uh
yeah yeah come up here uh get some
trading cards by buying a book or just
by sitting here uh talked to d foy he
drove in from minneapolis today and is
going to dc tomorrow so let's send them
off all right thanks everybody
oh of course
hold on i'm going to get my pin
[Music]
each issue should be handled differently
but i have a general philosophy that i'm
approaching all issues it starts